let's talk briefly about this entire
dust-up with Meryl Streep and the Golden
Globes and president elect Donald after
receiving an award at Sunday night's
Golden Globes actress Meryl Streep gave
the speech where without mentioning
Trump by name she slammed Trump for
making fun of a disabled reporter surge
Kowalewski here's a quote from Meryl
Streep where she said there was one
performance this year that stunned me it
sank its hooks in my heart not because
it was good there was nothing good about
it but it was effective and it did its
job
it made its intended audience laugh and
show their teeth it was that moment when
the person asking to sit in the most
respected seat in our country imitated a
disabled reporter someone he outranked
and privileged power and the capacity to
fight back it kind of broke my heart
when I saw it and I still can't get it
out of my head because it wasn't in a
movie it was in real life what was Meryl
Streep referring to she was referring to
this when Donald Trump mimicked mocked a
disabled reporter take a look written by
a nice reporter now the poor guy you got
to see this guy I don't know what I said
I don't remember he's gonna like how to
remember I thought maybe that's what I
said this is 14 years ago he still they
didn't do a retraction that reporter he
is talking about his Serge kovaleski who
now works for the New York Times as he
can seem right there he suffers from a
chronic condition that impairs movement
of his arms right a Thai spokesman says
they find it outrageous that Trump would
ridicule the man's appearance so
president-elect Donald Trump instead of
saying hey you know what I was wrong to
mock him denied it and fired back at
Meryl Streep on Twitter three tweets
back-to-back that Donald Trump sent out
we will start with the first one here
where Donald Trump said Meryl Streep one
of the most overrated actresses in
Hollywood doesn't know me but attacked
last night at the Golden Globes going on
to say she is a Hillary flunky who lost
big for the hundredth time I never
mocked the disabled reporter would never
do that but simply showed him
groveling when he totally changed a 16
year old story that he had written in
order to make me look bad just more very
dishonest me
there's so many layers to this guy's
number one Trump is triggered so easily
right if Trump is triggered this easily
by Meryl Streep at an awards show how on
earth can he handle being president it's
laughable but there's another issue here
which is there's no doubt to me that
Donald Trump mocked a disabled reporter
in a way that mimicked his disability
but the broader story is Trump mocks
people that is a broader issue that's
not being discussed which is yes this
particular mocking of surge Kowalewski
is absolutely deplorable and horrible
but shouldn't we also be concerned more
generally about the president-elect or
someone who at the time wanted to be
President just mocking people at all and
good luck yet no Trump is care about
that that's fine at this point yeah I
think he would do best just to stay out
of the spat I mean if you look back at
some of the more harmful offensive
things he said on the campaign trail
things like Mexico is sending rapists
and criminals he can kind of backtrack
and say oh well I was talking about the
Mexican government this is an
open-and-shut case I mean there's no
defending this and there's one other
aspect of this Rachel that I think is
really notable here which is he attacked
Meryl Streep initially because she's not
a good actress and that's what's also
another thing that that is not being
discussed that much which is Trump
couldn't just go back at her about the
allegation she made about the mocking he
had to start by saying she's a bad
actress even though in 2015 he actually
said good things about her Trump can't
combat someone verbally without
attacking them on a personal level he
can't just go after what they said yeah
it's a very childish way of interacting
and arguing but you also know that you
must be doing something a little bit
wrong if Joe Scarborough is saying stop
tweeting yeah right when Joe Scarborough
lets you know you may want to ease up on
the tweets you know you're doing
something wrong because Joe Scarborough
not exactly the representative of
restraint when it comes to social media
so but 10 days 10 days before the
inauguration what's Donald Trump doing
well I guess it was 11 days yesterday
when he did this he's fighting with
Meryl Streep on Twitter that's what the
president-elect is doing
trumpets explain to me how this is a
good use of the president elects time
and energy thanks for watching this
video
for you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the David
Pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated